так на Чернігівщині готуються
оборонятися від ворога військовий Олег
проводить нас сотнями метрів виритих у
полі траншей чим більше у таких
поворотів більше повороту втім більше
спасіння Осколки менше летять поняли
вони получаються за счёт повороту ти
забігаєш за повороти заховався забігаєш
заховався отстрадався перебіг
Чим більше тим більше живе
пригодяться не пригодяться будемо
працювати ми за Україну Слава україні
більшість цих споруд копали Полкові
землерині машини а рівняють і підчищають
вручну до таких робіт залучають місцевих
безробітних для цього уряд запровадив
спеціальну програму армію відновлення
Сергій один з її бійців оце робив
ступеньки я до ступеньок
все було
не я один все ми копали
Дари метрів вниз
один викидає другий копає попри
товариству атмосферу і корисно для
регіону роботу чоловік сумує за своєю
професією він родом з Чернігівщини але
все життя прожив у дружківці на
Донеччині за своїм фахом 56-річний
чоловік не може знайти роботу Токар раз
працювальник розташувальник
все життя після служби в армії шахтний
оборудование завод згодом какую-то
частину і шахтного оборудования выполняв
я і станок подавався і робота подалася і
колектив після того часу як знайшлася
війна всі як пропала Сергій просився до
місцевої тероборони але не взяли Тому
вже другий місяць Він допомагає
військовим як може
[музика]
інші безробітні разом з електриками
розчищають гілля 59-річний Василь у
минулому працював на залізниці потім
охоронцем роботу втратив ще до війни
подумки чоловік із сином який воює під
бахмутом він пішов добровольців я його
понімаю тому що це
він так почитав нурсм і правильний і я
його подержила рішення Хотів мислях но
піддерживав потому що його батько і
так сказати Я надіюся що він живий із
перемогою прийде тому я пішов на це
роботу по тому що надо і місту помогти
по благоустрію і думаю що ми нашим дітям
тоже поглошуємо які вони на війні така ж
мотивація і в 24-річного Єгора хоча би
якусь користь приносимо тому що місту бо
хлопці зараз там на передовій А ми хотя
би тут щось робимо для нашого міста що
те щоб якось чисто було хлопці захищають
ми зачищаємо місце можна так сказати
Єгора молода дружина і дев'ятимісячний
малюк через війну м'ясокомбінат де
працював хлопець скоротив штат під
скорочення потрапив і Єгор багато де на
виробництвох по сокращалися місця де
багато зараз що критерії там дуже високі
треба тобто в мене не закінчено у мене
Такі один із класів спеціальної в мене
цієї немає
працював то вантажником то підсобним
робітником зараз дуже складно знайти то
що зараз всі хто міг ти і вже вакансії
позаймали Ну А так поки перебуваємо з
тим що єсть і те Ну тоже гарно
до суспільно корисних робіт за урядовою
армією відновлення безробітних залучають
місцеві центри зайнятості тим хто стоїть
на обліку пропонують роботи на якій є
запит від комунальних чи бюджетних
підприємств розбирати завали заготовляти
дрова укріплювати дамби чистити узбіччя
це здебільшого фізично складні роботи
тож для жінок можливостей небагато хоча
серед безробітних є більше ніж чоловіків
для жінок такої роботи немає крім
підготовки от оцих цивільних споруд ну
тобто підвалів для укриттів там була
робота для жінок прибирання
білили стіни Ну І от плетіння сіток
зарплата 6700 грн вона вища ніж середній
виплати за безробіттям на Чернігівщині
це трохи більше 4 тисяч гривень тоді як
в міністерстві економіки наголошують що
працевлаштування на суспільно-корисні
роботи добровільне у чернігівському
обласному центрі зайнятості пояснюють що
це не зовсім так якщо безробітні
відмовляються від запропонованих робіт
то їх знімають з обліку відповідно і
виплат вони отримувати не будуть якщо
цей чоловік відмовляється ви бачили цих
чоловіків ну здорових нормальних
чоловіків вони з якоюсь причини ж не
служать в армії то Хай працюють в армії
Відродження я розумію Я так розумію були
такі що відмовлялися кажуть мені
спеціалісти Але після роз'яснення
вони погодилися окрім Чернігівщини
програма працює також на Сумщині
Полтавщині Донеччині Київщині Рівненщині
загалом же армія відновлення поки
нагадує радше полк по Україні до неї
долучені наразі лише 1054 особи тоді як
усього безробітних за даними
мінекономіки близько двох з половиною
мільйонів у центрах зайнятості
зареєстровані 225 тисяч осіб навряд чи
зможемо ми залучити всіх до цих робіт
про те ми виходимо тут з сюжету і ми
розуміємо що загальний обсяг
фінансування цих робіт становить в цьому
році 20 мільйонів гривень і сьогодні ми
про фінансували вже таких робіт на майже
5 мільйонів гривень тому ми розуміємо що
найперше - це потреба яка потреба буде
оголошена Крім того в уряді визнають
армія відновлення це лише один із
механізмів боротьби з безробіттям урочи
із грантовими програмами для підприємств
і стимулами для бізнесу
працевлаштовувати безробітних водночас
наступного року розраховують щоби з
роботи можуть залишитися ще більше до
двох і вісім мільйонів людей